that's a different form of reality and
it augments
our sense of the language hi there steve
kaufman here
and today i want to talk about
augmented reality and how it applies to
language learning how it can
improve uh the efficiency of our
learning experience remember if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe uh
click on the bell for notifications
if you listen to these as podcasts on
some podcast servers like spotify
apple music or whatever please leave a
review it's greatly appreciated
so
to explain why i sort of came up with
this idea of augmented reality
a couple of things first of all
i have been focusing on my persian for
the last couple of weeks
uh doing a lot of listening
uh taking uh you know youtube videos
taking the url creating an mp3 file
posting it on happyscribe creating the
transcript importing it into link and
working on that daily listening reading
linking
also studying some of the items in our
library uh on history
the story of musa for example who was a
very famous politician in iran who was
got shafted by the american cia and
british mi
six back in 1953 or whatever it was
anyway so dealing in sort of
not
actually interacting with people and
then speaking with my tutor
two three times a week in uh but again
through skype
and last friday i had an appointment
with my doctor my doctor is iranian
and uh so i go to the office there and
they have the uh you know the reception
staff and so forth so they're speaking
persian with each other i start speaking
persian with them i hear real live
people speaking persian
so
you know which is the reality which is
the
virtual world obviously these people are
the reality however it's the interaction
of my
studying the language which could be in
books which could be as i say listening
to podcasts watching movies i did watch
some movies in in persian
uh
interacting via skype with my tutor
but then when you go on you interact
with real life people
it it it augments that reality
it's it's an amazing feeling to for me
it was at any rate to be there having
listened to so much persian and hearing
real life people actually speak in
person
so that was fun to do
and of course it was fun to sense that
my persian has improved a lot
but
i found then that uh driving back home
from the doctor's office listening to
my usual persian content
i heard it better it was more clear to
me so that what i take away from that is
that the sort of the interaction of
different modes of learning
is extremely important i've often said
you know we need variety in our language
learning uh we need to listen and read
and talk
and we need variety in terms of the kind
of content we're using and i also think
that you know i don't think speaking
with someone with a tutor via skype or
zoom is the same thing as interacting
with someone face to face that's a
different form of reality
and it augments
our sense of the language it our it
increases our motivation of course it
also increases our focus
and so uh you know when we think of of
say learning a language for example
people typically think of being in a
classroom
and particularly if we're talking about
kids the bulk of their waking time is
not in a classroom the bulk of their
waking time is away from the classroom
so the whole the whole idea sort of of
education
should focus in on how do we create so
many different
learning environments learning spaces
learning opportunities that take place
partly in a classroom
partly when i'm one-on-one with my tutor
via skype partly when i'm listening to
whatever i'm missing to you know a
political podcast or something in
persian
but also other opportunities like this
opportunity that i had in the doctor's
office now it's often difficult to
create these opportunities and i have
spoken before about how i i work very
hard on a language with the intention of
going to the country and then once you
go there and you're surrounded by this
language that you've been listening to
and learning and now everybody's using
it like it's no longer sort of
something that you artificially learn
it's actually the real world
so that real world
and i would even borrow the term
augmented reality if you go to
if i were to go to iran or when i went
to greece or or wherever or morocco
and you can actually communicate with
people and understand even imperfectly
what they're saying
to my mind that augments the reality
that you experience of being in that
environment
so
you know i'm just saying that there are
so many things we can do
to
to learn a language one nothing is
exclusive nothing
excludes doing something else and the
greater the variety of
you know interaction or or connection
with the language
the better we do
and the more our sort of language world
is is the intensity of that experience
is augmented
so i just wanted to share that with you
uh and uh
i thought this i liked i looked up
augmented reality on the internet and
it's it seems to be this sense of
using computers to augment reality but
but i think it goes in both directions
when it comes to language learning so
just throw that out there and i look
forward to hearing your comments